[Music]
why did you do an agency so me and sam
always talk about like uh we have many
mottos on this podcast
for example we don't do public math
for example you don't say you're rich
you say you're post-economic uh these
are things we've picked up from from
guests along the way and one of the one
of the model one of the mottos that we
say
is uh you know
agencies suck
and uh it's like
and and the reason we say is not because
they uh like they do well that's not
that they suck it's like they suck as a
business choice like if i could i've
always thought if i could choose between
software or an agency i'd do software
because it's like oh it's not a services
business it's going to work while i
sleep and it can scale up and i don't
have to open up offices in poland and
brazil and all these other places
but you chose that you did software and
you chose agency now
why'd you make that choice and what's
great about agencies that i'm
kind of like not giving enough credit
for
so you're looking at business as in
software is more scalable it's more
desirable by public market ex hubspot
versus
accenture etc has
way worse multiples than hubspot
accenture is a bigger company from a
revenue even a standpoint but now take a
different approach okay i hope publicly
traded companies you guys are both
hubspot employees i'm assuming still is
that correct
kinda
sure whatever your guys's deal is right
but you guys are pretty much at hubspot
now imagine creating a business and you
don't plan on going public you don't
care for the limelight you don't care
for any of that in business
what's a successful business
good revenue growth and good revenue and
profitability right
all that really matters at the end of
the day whether you grow or not grow is
how profitable are you would you guys
agree with that statement assuming
you're doing something that's ethical
and you're not selling drugs no
i wouldn't agree with that i would say
there's a third thing which is like is
this enjoyable and like do i like my
day-to-day and with the more people you
have
most people would say that's just a
little bit more headache uh than
than but that's not software or
consulting anytime you build a big
company you tend to have a large amount
of people whether it's hubspot or
whether it's accenture everyone has yeah
but you can have you can probably have a
much higher revenue per employee with
software versus let's say you own a
massive landscaping business you're
gonna have to have tens of thousands of
people
but what's the difference from dealing
with how many people does hubspot have
like six thousand i don't know five
thousand six thousand is probably a lot
i'm guessing on the number but what's
the difference of dealing with
five thousand or six thousand people and
twenty thousand people there's a point
where it doesn't matter and it's a lot
of people either way
like it's not like you're at 50 people
you still have thousands of employees to
deal with and you need managers and
layers and all that kind of stuff yeah
but you're hiring at some
good or bad you're hiring a different
type of person so for example if you're
vaynermedia they're based in new york
they can probably only afford to pay
some of their
lower level employees 70 or 80 000 a
year and so you just have to get a ton
of people like that and have to have
higher churn versus say a bigger company
where you're able to pay a significantly
higher salary because the revenue per
employee is much higher so
perhaps there's a slightly different
day-to-day with because of that not
necessarily let's say you're a
vaynermedia he could be doing it to
optimize for profit ones if i told you
his ltv was six seven eight years
right and you know that's great
then at that point you can still hire
high quality people and pay my arm and a
leg
you got what i mean right like you look
at the accent
they're charging accounts so much money
and their contracts are long and i don't
know what vaynermedia's ltv is but
there's a lot of consulting companies
that have ltvs of six seven years for
clients
and their clients are spending you know
a hubspot yes there's more revenue per
you can say potentially in software you
can get to more revenue per employee but
i know consulting companies that only
take on contracts that are like five six
million dollars and upwards
so you have high margins and you can
have a high revenue per employee but
either way no matter what as you build a
big business you're going to need more
people and it's a headache to manage
whether you pay them 70 000 or whether
you pay them 150 000 it's still more of
a headache and the notion that if you
hire someone for 150 000 i'm not saying
you're saying this it doesn't
necessarily mean they're a better
employee right and you know it just
means different types of headaches
correct exactly engineers for example
are very expensive in this economy right
so
the point i'm getting at is a consulting
company i had the demand for it a lot of
people want to pay me for marketing and
there was just so much demand it would
have been silly not to do and if i'm not
trying to go public or i'm not trying to
sell
money is money green is green as long as
you're happy doing what you're doing
take the cash will you ever sell the
company
i wouldn't say i would never sell the
company but i don't care to ever sell
the company because i love what i'm
doing
we also have good growth too right like
i don't know what will grow this year
60 something percent which isn't bad
you know with the market going up and
down and fluctuating 60 something
percent is my guess at our size is
decent yeah the part i was actually
talking about was a little bit more like
i think you're you're totally right that
like if you're gonna win big you're
gonna end up with a bunch of employees
and like you know it might look like 150
might look like a thousand it might look
like 10 000 but like you know in either
case you're gonna have managerial work
and headaches and it's just different
types
the part i was really talking about is
like you know i've now built let's say a
media company content and then it's like
um
done educational stuff so courses which
are like you know a different thing and
then there's like a built software
company and you know we ended up selling
that one and then it's like and then
there's um
uh services which is like client
services like like consulting or agency
model
and what i hate what i what i love about
content media is it's actually pretty
fun to create and it's cool because a
lot of people consume it so they kind of
you know you get that like hit um
but you got to like you got to bake the
cake every day right so like you know
the hustle or like the milk road or this
podcast like we have to come on and
create the content again uh you know for
the most part we we're not doing like
super long evergreen stuff uh so you
know like with the hustles the daily
news that our milk roads a daily
newsletter it's we gotta bake that cake
every day whereas software it was like
we built one product and yes we might we
will improve it over the course of a
year you know every year we're gonna
improve it
but like fundamentally um
we didn't have to like recreate the
product come up with a new viral story
or a new great content segment uh that
would like require like a new genius uh
with software it's like you come up with
one genius moment and then you sort of
refine it make it work better over time
and get rid of bugs and things like that
so i prefer that part of software which
was like making a product rather than
making kind of like a disposable
uh you know consumable piece of content
or like i have an e-commerce company and
like it's the pain in the ass to have
supply physical products that are supply
chain
constrained and like we have a warehouse
we got warehouse problems with our
e-commerce business and so i'm like man
digital was sweet compared to e-commerce
but e-commerce is quite profitable that
kicks off a bunch of profits that's nice
so every business has these pros and
cons and i always thought agency was
like
um
the part i always thought was a pain in
the ass was like the client services you
are reinventing the next campaign and
the next winning marketing you know
formula for them
and you have to keep clients happy all
the time and clients are sort of like
never satisfied in a way that like
they if software is like you can have
nameless faceless customers that like
yeah some percentage of them will go
right into your help desk that's in the
philippines or whatever but like you're
not having to like
you know send account reports to your
you know your your big clients and keep
them happy
yeah but you everyone has their own
problems and software a lot of people
have turned this issue and they can't
figure it out or they have competitors
who come into the marketplace and just
undercut them on pricing for the same
features because it's cheaper and
cheaper to build software these days
right so they all have their own problem
to me i look at it as if you can find
the right people so every time i start a
company i find in people to put in place
that have already done it multiple times
before because your risk of failure are
lower and they already know everything
to do so i don't have to deal with
client relationships i don't have to
deal with customer service or anything
like that i get to do what i enjoy doing
which is go and create content be the
face etc and uh my wife enjoys what she
gets to do right she gets to donate the
money although we don't really consider
it as donations we look at as investing
we're investing in people although we
really don't ever collect any money back
it's more so you're investing into
making the world a better place for
people's lives a better place or
whatever it may be
what's uh who were
who were your first three clients
at this at this agent because
i don't know they were small companies
and right now who's an example client
like
a fortune 100 software company
like that is a typical company think of
any big large corporation in b2b that's
a great example of one of our customers
or even b2c actually think of any
fortune 500 company that's a prime
example of a customer
what's uh and who's the ceo of your
agency are you
no i'm never the ceo i'm a terrible
manager i'm one of the worst managers
ever uh his name is mike gullickson he
was the ceo no he was the president of
iprospect which is an ad agency owned by
uh densu i believe in i prospect maybe
they have four or five thousand people
is my guess
and what when you
how early into the business did you have
a hired ceo or hired leader
day one i won't start a business without
a ceo from daylight and what did you pay
them in the first year
first year was my co-founder for like a
hundred grand
and that's because you basically went
and drummed up 100 grand worth of
business and you're like hey mike uh i
got i got those clients to give a
hundred grand do you wanna run this
thing for me and help it get deployed
no uh our business didn't start off that
way i probably put a total of five
million bucks into the business and my
own money so it was bootstrap but not
really bootstrapped if that makes sense
it's kind of cheating
and it gets easier and easier as your
entrepreneur right the more
the more successes you have and i'm not
saying i'm successful by any means the
more capital you have to deploy into the
next thing so reduces chances of
failure
and when it's your own money this is
just my
thesis and i could be wrong on this i
have no data points when it's your own
money you're much more careful than when
if you raise like 15 20 30 million
dollars of venture capital right you
really look at every single dollar uh
but mike was the ceo from day one he's a
great operator has no agency experience
eventually we got in a president and
then eventually from there we got in a
ceo
and have you guys crossed a hundred
million in revenue yet
yeah we do nine figures
that's crazy man so
what i mean that's just pretty wild that
you're able to like parlay this blog
that was already always kind of a
juggernaut but this blog into a
nine figure a year business i mean
that's amazing
yeah
it's been a
good run i hope it
i'm knocking on wood although you
probably can't hear because of chris but
uh i hope it keeps going and more so
we're just having fun like for me what i
enjoy doing is building a business um i
know i have an expensive lifestyle i
generally don't do stuff for the money
like i overpay like house staff like
nannies and stuff like that when i say
overpay i drastically overpaid not by
like 10 20 30 40 like i really mean
drastically over pay because i look at
people i'm like if you're cleaning the
house how are you gonna live on this
like i'll give someone six figures to do
that i know that sounds kind of crazy or
stupid but like i'm not giving my kids
money so might as well take care of
other people in this world who need it
more than um
but we do
[Music]
in the pirate business it's easy to fall
into forcing sales but hubspot helps us
treat our valued customers like people
not conquests
how's your tailbird i brought you a case
of rob
hubspot grow better